[Musique]
il
c'est devenu effectivement un
moment de partage tellement énorme est
tellement chargée d'émotion entre
l'intergénérationnel et puis l'intérêt
du bien public
le plaisir d'améliorer le vivre en ce
sens c'est pour nous saluer ça a été
l'événement de l'événement est forcément
aujourd'hui il ya inscrit à notre agenda
on avait une impression que les gens ne
se connaissaient pas et on a quelques
exemples pour vous dire qu'ils ont fait
c'est d'abord avant tout un état
d'esprit c'est la liberté de participer
on est sur la base du volontariat dans
envie de faire quelque chose dans ta
commune c'est un problème d'égalité
parce que que tu sois maire que tu sois
technicien tu sois
petit nom il n'y a pas de différence on
est tous sentent même pas toile à
l'espace de cette journée
c'est un prétexte cette journée
citoyenne c'est aussi pour créer du lien
en continu entre les élus locaux les
citoyens que les citoyens comprennent ce
que les élus locaux font au quotidien ce
que les agents techniques on a entendu
tout à l'heure le regard qui change par
rapport à l'action des agents municipaux
donc tout ça c'est aussi ça s'entretient
au fil de l'eau fil de l'eau tout au
long de l'année pour construire pour
choisir les chantiers qui sont proposés
dans sept jours des citoyennes donc
c'est du lien cedus et de la citoyenneté
en fait
[Musique]
aimez-vous laquelle il s'agit d'aller
voter
nous y allaient de bon coeur vous y
allez pas
riba
si on veut vraiment avoir tous les
arguments notre position qui nous
permettent un véritable travail concret
il faut s'approprier la richesse des
initiatives locales qui peut y avoir et
on ne peut le faire
cal se déplaçant et en étant directement
au contact avec ces gens de terrain qui
pourront nous exprimer toutes les
expériences qui sont les leurs pour nous
nous permettre après d'avoir donc
suffisamment d'arguments pour travailler